stromberg in rheinland pfalz das
bundesumweltministerium möchte tanken
teurer machen
eine co2 steuer auf benzin heizöl und
gas soll den klimawandel bremsen
wir zahlen schon genug sonst nichts was
sollte sich überlegen ob man nicht das
gros der bevölkerung arbeitnehmer
versucht er so entlasten als dass man
ihnen noch was drauf packt ja also ich
selber bin auf ihre klimaschutz und der
natur man sieht was sehen da passiert
mit der natur das wird ja immer
schlimmer
nein ich muss ja autofahren die folgen
des klimawandels sind links sichtbar
auch in deutschland es droht der kollaps
des planeten
schuld daran zu viel co2 dabei hatte
sich deutschland verpflichtet emissionen
drastisch zu senken
das war im jahr 2015 auf der pariser
konferenz
noch vor zwei jahren versicherte die
bundeskanzlerin
ich sage wir werden wege finden wie wir
bis 2020 unter 40 prozent ziel einhalten
das verspreche ich ihnen doch dieses
versprechen ist nicht einzuhalten
deutschland verpasst seine klimaziele
dabei gäbe es eine lösung meint der
klima experte und berater der
bundesregierung ottmar edenhofer um
endlich mehr kohlenstoffdioxid
einzusparen brauche es eine abgabe die
co2 bepreisung ist es
kosteneffizienteste mittel co2 zu
reduzieren
und es ist auch das sozial gerechteste
weil damit auch die einnahmen entstehen
die wir verwenden können um die sozial
schwachen zu entlasten
sein modell jede tonne co2 wird zunächst
mit 40 euro belastet die steuereinnahmen
verbleiben aber nicht beim staat sondern
werden größtenteils wieder an die bürger
zurückgegeben
ein beispiel
eine familie mit zwei kindern auf dem
land mit einem verdienst von rund 42.000
euro netto würde so im jahr mit gerade
mal 17 euro belastet werden
eine alleinstehende rentnerin die am
stadtrand wohnt und mit 7400 euro netto
im jahr ungefähr das existenzminimum
erreicht gewinnt sogar sie hat 40 euro
mehr im jahr
die co2 steuer sei der sozial
verträglichste weg den ausstoß von
kohlenstoffdioxid zu begrenzen meint der
wissenschaftler
es gibt zur co2 steuer nur die
alternative dass wir zum beispiel
verbote oder gebote aussprechen also zum
beispiel ein diesel fahrverbot aber ein
diesel fahrverbot hat sehr viel mehr und
größere soziale verwerfungen als eine
besteuerung von diesel also von daher
wäre das bessere weg wiesbaden die firma
bernd schilly verkauft heizöl und diesel
seit über 40 jahren
nun sollen die treibstoffe noch stärker
besteuert werden
die mitarbeiter bekommen die ängste der
kunden zu spüren sich in zukunft das
heizen womöglich nicht mehr leisten zu
können
hinzu kommt wird der staat tatsächlich
die co2 steuer an die bürger zurückgeben
die zweifel bei firmeninhaber darin
sitzen tief
es gibt für mich keinen sinn weil da
wird wieder im riesen papierkrieg
aufgebaut geld von links nach rechts
verschoben
aber es wird keiner so richtig einsehen
warum das ganze passiert und es kommt
sicherlich auch nachher bei den
verbrauchern ruckzuck die frage kriege
ich das geld nach ihr wirklich wieder
zurück oder versinkt es nicht in
irgendeinem staatshaushalt sowie bei der
ökosteuer kaum ökologische effekte dafür
geld für die rentenkassen für viele
etikettenschwindel
die schweiz hier funktioniert die co2
steuer schon seit über zehn jahren und
die bürger erhalten geld zurück im
engadin wohnt die familie von martina
und not vital
sie führen einen kleinen
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb produzieren
gemüse fleisch wolle mit umgerechnet 84
euro wird jede tonne co2 in der schweiz
belastet ein großteil der einnahmen gibt
der staat über die krankenkasse den
bürgern zurück wir haben es ausgerechnet
das sind etwa 350 franken im jahr
momentan tendenz steigend also die ist
jedes jahr steigt die rückerstattung
deshalb wissen jetzt auch nicht genau
und dann ja da kann man schon einmal
richtig gut essen gern damit umgerechnet
rund 300 euro im jahr also für die vital
zwei drittel der einnahmen aus der co2
steuer werden direkt an die bürger
ausgeschüttet ein drittel geht in die
energetische sanierung von gebäuden
früher waren diese räume nicht isoliert
war nur sondern natürlich die ganze
wärme dort herausgeputzt in der schweiz
werden bisher benzin und diesel nicht
mit der co2 steuer belegt doch das ist
in der politischen diskussion so ähnlich
wie in der schweiz könnte eine co2
steuer auch in deutschland funktionieren
doch bislang gibt es hier nicht einmal
einen gesetzentwurf lediglich
modellrechnungen nachfrage zur co2
steuer bei der zuständigen
umweltministerin svenja schulze gestern
auf dem petersberger klimadialog was
sind die konkreten gründe dass wir immer
noch diskutieren und es immer noch mit
der umsetzung hapert
sie können mir glauben dass ich als
umweltministerin da sehr viel druck
machen um das schneller voran zu
bekommen ich wünsche mir dass das
schneller geht ist hier macht seitdem
ich im amt bin da sehr viel druck doch
die umweltministerin scheitert an
koalitionspartner
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass es
intelligentere methoden gibt als einfach
zu sagen wir müssen eine steuer erheben
oder eine steuer erhöhen
nur welche methode auf diese frage hat
die klima kanzlerin angela merkel keine
antwort und auch keine klare position
zur co2 steuer stattdessen heute ein
eingeständnis und neue versprechen wir
haben dann gesagt von 2010 bis 2020
wollen wir noch mal 20 prozent schaffen
und das erweist sich doch jetzt als
nicht ganz einfach
umso mehr fühlen wir uns verpflichtet
jetzt bei den zielen für 2030 auch ganz
deutlich zu machen die müssen wir
erreichen
seit jahren diskussionen ohne ergebnis
vertagt zeit meinen experten
wer nicht handelt muss bei anderen
emissionsrechte kaufen und für den
deutschen bundeshaushalt wenn wir so
weitermachen wie bisher werden dass
kosten von 30 bis 60 milliarden in den
nächsten zehn jahren werden das kann
richtig teuer werden
diese kosten würden wir alle tragen über
unsere steuern
eine co2 steuer bietet die chance den
klimawandel zu verlangsamen
doch nur wenn es der politik gelingt die
bürger von dieser idee zu überzeugen
[Musik]